[Laughter]
[Music]
hello
in today's video blender 2.8 and using
it as a video editor always use blender
as a video editor and I found it's
pretty good for that just because you
can do almost every effect although I
don't know how to do every effect yet I
admit but I know the basics of how to
get a video rendering that will work for
any generic situation so I want to show
you that so first of all you do need to
go to blender.org download blender 2.8
and unpack it I've unpacked it too on my
desktop here and then you go into that
folder you unpack it too and run the
blender make a shortcut to this if you
want there will be a lot of updates so
some of these things might change in a
minor way but overall it should stay the
same ok so what we're gonna do is I'm
just gonna walk you through from the
starting screen to getting an actual
thing rendering properly so that you can
upload it to a place like say YouTube
there are a few nuances here that if you
miss you'll be sort of out of luck and
once you launch it you should get this
screen this is default I haven't changed
anything here one thing that's different
from 2.79 is there's no just video
editing thing drop down you have to
click this plus up here and go to it and
then you'll get to a screen that looks
more like it's for video editing in this
area here is your I think it's called a
sequencer yep sequencer you can zoom out
with the mouse wheel oh it's right click
to move around now okay so the left and
right click were changed by default on
blender 2.8 in case you don't know that
yet so what used to be left click is now
right click and of course this is the
start point of your render and this over
here is the end point of your render you
can change that by going down here and
typing in the new number if you zoom out
and go to where you want it to go you'll
see where you're at and you can change
this one to the same number
and that's where your render will be now
okay so before we even drop in a video
here I want to go through these
properties over here because these are
really important you see it has a 1080
default resolution and it's 100% if you
change this percent down it'll render
faster but it'll be lower quality this
can be good for doing demo renders just
to make sure things turn out as you
expect if you want to just do the render
quickly at a lower quality but when
you're ready to do your full thing
that's the highest quality possible--
you want to crank this up of course so
there's the start and end frames which
are the same as being edited down there
this frame rate should auto adjust to
your video type so if you have multiple
different videos at different frame
rates that could get a little weird but
it should auto detect whatever video you
drag and drop into here and turn it to
the correct frame rate I usually record
at 60fps so this should turn to 60fps
once I drop the video in here but a few
more quick things before I drop a video
in here and go to rendering something
you look at your output and change that
to somewhere where you know so by
default this puts it on your route drive
under a folder called temp so it's
usually usually your C Drive under temp
is the default probably not the best
spot if you ask me but it depends and
then you'll notice it says P and G here
we probably don't want to do it as a
bunch of PNG s you can do it as a bunch
of peonies it'll render every frame as a
PNG with this method I usually switch it
to ffmpeg video this is great for
uploading to say YouTube then you also
want to go to encoding this encoding is
super important if you miss this you
will not get any sound so go to encoding
leave it all the same leave it all the
same up for audio and change this audio
codec to AAC that seems to work great
these defaults seem to work fine I
wouldn't mess with any of these on any
video clip you can manually adjust the
volume so I would recommend just leaving
and manually adjusting them on your on
your video clip audio if need be I
usually leave this at medium quality it
seems to be fine going any higher makes
your files massive so maybe maybe you
need even higher quality but I don't
really notice any loss at medium and
it's still pretty big file but if you
want it to be even higher quality and a
much larger file even you can do that so
I think medium is fine I leave all these
the same
ok so let's drop in a small video and
I'll give you a quick sample of how to
do things so when you drop in a video I
believe it's gonna start at wherever
your cursor so I'm holding right click
here and just move my cursor and I want
to look for a small video I am going to
get rid of this little file area I guess
I'll do a Python console for now I'm
gonna bring in this fifty three kilobyte
file and there you can see my my doo-dah
Arc a little clip of me taming a dino
but as you right click around there's a
bit of a delay as it syncs up the video
now if you want this delay to go away
you can hide this I don't know I'll just
turn it to another sequence there but if
it doesn't have to render the video
image as you click around it goes a lot
faster so here we have our files our our
file stuff one of these is a video file
and one of these is an audio file and
you can tell by left clicking on it and
you see what you get over here so the
audio one let's look at it first real
quick here because there's something
that I always do ok audio ones this
lighter cyan one not the purplish one if
you highlight your audio one you can
click display waveform and you'll see
the waveform of your audio this can
often help pick out the important parts
where you're explaining something or
where something's happening or the
action is so seeing this audio can
really help and it's a lot faster to
scan through it than it is
with a preview because the problem with
this preview is it just lags so much
when you go to switch to a different
part i've already right clicked waiting
waiting waiting it just takes so so long
to flip around to your video so you
probably want to do a mix of of those
depending on what you're doing and ok
let's let's explain a few other basic
things if you select a video clip hold
shift you can multi-select and then you
can left-click to unselect if you hold
ctrl and select one I think these are
actually slightly different lengths that
came in as different lengths but I think
if you hold ctrl and left click it
selects everything with the same length
which isn't working here because these
are slightly different so what I'm going
to do is I'm actually going to grab this
audio one by the end if you click the
little end arrow and you can zoom way in
if you can't see those because your
videos too short or something you can
click the end press a G and and start
moving it and if you hold ctrl here
it'll snap so if I hold ctrl it snaps T
and now these should be about the same
as long as the start is the same do the
same thing here press G hold control
looks like it starts at one it tells you
the start frames there and now if I hold
ctrl and select it should select them
both because are the same so ctrl left
click to select matching ones G for grab
so after you click something to click
here in the center not the endpoints and
hid G you can grab and move it and you
can press X or Y to lock it to the X or
Y for example if I hit Y here I can only
move it up and down by X here I can only
move it left and right
so some hotkeys that come in handy there
we go got it lined up again so usually
if you work if you're clipping this say
I want to cut off a bit of the beginning
I'll control select get them both get my
little cursor where it once why they're
selected you press K for a cut and then
you can grab these ends and and clean
them up as you want and then you can
double you
select whatever's left press G jump in
the place if it gets read a little
that's usually okay usually snap you
gotta be careful with that if you hold
shift okay so you can move real quickly
if you hold shift it moves really slowly
so you can line things up carefully and
the layers do matter you can hit let's
see you can go somewhere else on here
anywhere you want with your cursor and
hit shift a to add something like you
might add text color you can bring in a
movie sound there's a lot of stuff to
play around with I'm not gonna go over
all these but shift a brings up the
general thing your properties pane over
whatever you have selected is here so
you can adjust that like maybe this
audio ended up way too quiet I can
select this audio and crank up the
volume or you can mess with pitch
there's a lot of things experiment with
here I'm really just showing you how to
kind of get it generally working with
some basic cuts not gonna go over all
the facts there's just so much you can
do with blender people do full movie
quality stuff with blender and of course
you can bring in your animations I
haven't even got to that phase yet I'm
just working with video clips and audio
and you can bring in P and G's and and
use let's see if you select something
that has video you can change the
opacity of it so if you're layering them
over top of each other you can you can
opacity stuff in so you can make an
image with [ __ ] or Photoshop for example
bring it in here with image or just drag
it in move it around stretch it out
change the pasty of it so you can layer
images over top your stuff - and there
are offsets crops that you can do I'm
gonna I'm gonna just do this like this
here so cut a little bit at the
beginning make it rather short let's see
and I'm gonna go all the way to the end
you can press Y you have your cursor
selected somewhere you're gonna hit page
up to go to the end or page down to go
to the start of the next cut so that
comes in handy sometimes
and then
right here where I wanted to end its 278
I'm going to change this to 278 that'll
get us nice and clean there of course if
you're doing a video maybe you want a
little outro area 20-second extra cut
here for example to add some outro and
maybe some intro or however you want to
do it that's up to you
so there we go looks good at 1080 100%
change to 60fps automatically because
this is a 60fps video so when you're
ready to render you can press ctrl f12
or you can go here and hit render
animation and this should start
rendering as you have your setup this
might lag out my video I don't know I
have it pop up this little demo thing
and show me the render but yeah that's
that's doing it you probably want to
leave your computer idle and don't mess
with other stuff while this is happening
depends on how powerful your computer is
but you can bug this out if you're
trying to do a bunch of other stuff Laos
rendering so if we got a long rendering
going just let it go if you're editing a
lot of really large video you're gonna
need an absolute beast of a machine for
it to keep up and not get really laggy
once you start adding effects and cuts
and layers your project will feel
progressively slower as you add more to
it so I've tried to do like our videos
and one edit with a bunch of effects and
it was a nightmare too you know you add
one effect and you have to wait like a
full minute for it to even load your
processing so just FYI that is a thing
that it's it's nice to have an editor
out there that works pretty reliably and
can do just about everything without
having having to pay a large sum of
money last thing this video did finish
I'm going to go to rendered and take a
look at it here there it is that by
default gives it the name of its time
1 2 3 31 so there it is if I double
click on it here looks like I got a
pretty high somehow turned into a 5
second video ok it's only a 5 second
video
it's a very short clip yeah there it is
zero five six seconds so it's really
short all right there it is legs 2.0
because the previous question and I'm
out I'll see you guys in the next video
thank you so much for watching
[Music]
[Applause]